hey guys it's Gary Vaynerchuk this is
the fifth pod sessions and as many of
you know this by the way if you've been
wondering why I've been throwing up my
entire hand in every photo that is
because it represents the number 5 which
is my favorite number if you haven't
seen the video the Jets jersey my mom
made for me literally Google Gary Vee
mom Jets Jersey
you have to watch this video number 5
has been my favorite number since I
turned 5 and decided my favorite number
was gonna be my age that is the fun fact
starting pod sessions I'm very excited
about this pod session and and what I
really want to do first and foremost is
go around the room and give everybody
who's listening a little bit of your who
you are and what you do and maybe five
seconds like the 5 second version of how
you got there and then we'll go into a
deeper so let's start - ladies first
right over here yeah oh hello everybody
my name is Arabella Ruby and I am an
actress and a CEO of my own company I
got my LLC 2017 January ruby-red
Enterprise and yeah it's been puffin
ever since Oh were you from I'm from
Augusta Georgia very nice born and
raised no I was actually born in England
oh okay yes my mom was in the Army for a
while but I'm actually British in
Jamaican so very cool so your childhood
in Georgia yes majority of masters yes
all of them home in a seven oh six yes
seven oh six and so you grew there and
so you live here now I live in a New
Jersey and I'm actually training
Patterson love it I know well and I am
training to become one of the best
actresses in the world in New York City
Georgia seven we just found that out yes
very nice for you jumping in before
being called on rich it's far away we'll
get back great to be here my name is
rich roll I am a recovering attorney
turned ultra endurance athlete host
podcasts that I've been doing since 2012
very successfully author thank you
successful Matt Joe thank you very much
contributed to crushing in which I was
very honored to do I'm in the biggest
way for everybody in a couple weeks what
do we have the official date
it's the third end or the eighth good I
understand
friends the audio book is finally coming
August 3rd or August 8th excuse me April
3rd or April 8th and rich did me a real
Mitzvah he read this for some of you
that have read it there's stories of
other people who read crush it and then
went on their way to and are featured
and crushing it and rich is one of those
people in the book who's affected by
crush it went on to crushing it but he
he actually is the voice behind the
stories of the audiobook I read most of
it and then Amy Wright is as the other
voice is that right Amy
Tyler pay attention Amy did the other
voices right yes yeah so I'm excited
about that you're a very big part of
crushing it which is actually crushing
it April 3rd
yeah April 3rd the feedback that I've
gotten from actually I'll go back to it
all right rich thrilled you're here you
live in the west coast here to do some
business I'm glad you stopped by the pod
sessions gape no man how are you I'm
excellent how are you good who are you
gabriel anderson i actually run our
Vayner beta business which was our small
and mid market business then working
alongside of Gary for five and half 1
was six years now also from LA
originally he pulled me out of my
startup from Santa Monica convinced me
that what I was doing was [ __ ] and if
I come execute on a much bigger platform
and hasn't been wrong and I really
appreciate Gabe because Antonio
Cromartie former star football player
New York jet was supposed to be here but
he's living the football player life
[ __ ] bailed
crow I'm gonna find you
I can't wait to have you I and so I
literally was like well game's [ __ ]
super interesting actually we start real
backwards game yeah to make this a show
yeah and what I'm honestly why you're on
cuz I know you won't be scared tell us a
story that I don't even know about me
from your 5 and a half a foot tell me a
story when you go out to dinner yeah
yeah yeah swishing now that I'm like on
the verge of becoming a famous person on
earth you're gonna have to deal with
this more often and you have to deal
with you know what you're gonna go out
with your lovely girl and you're gonna
have dinner and eventually oh you work
for that guy tell me some story what's a
good story that you can go to give me a
give me a story that I don't even know
good or bad like just a give me a funny
story something and you know you know my
own yes yeah that's maybe a less or or
something to be even more specific given
this audience what's a story you know I
find you to be very entrepreneurial your
own story you've been here for a while
you're you're crushing now with Vayner
beta we you were listen for this
audience you are the reason that I
finally feel confident that we're about
to help businesses that really want to
work with me the SMB is the startup see
entrepreneurs but what's a good story of
something you've got taught that was
totally different than the way you
thought about things or just a funny
story or like give us a story yeah so
the one that immediately comes to mind
is and in story form not dairy taught me
to be patient yeah yeah no no the the
the story that come immediately comes to
mind is I don't think you know the full
story of why I came out to New York in
the first place so I I had a startup
though we were doing dog [ __ ] back off
his transaction real estate management
for for realtors and and I see it so the
way that I I found out about the
business growing vaynermedia growing
Garrison's out of tweet one that I think
put posted on Facebook as well and you
know it was just vaynermedia's growing
we're looking for talented folks you
know and I'd followed him on YouTube for
about two three years of him to that
point and so I cold emailed him sent him
off a bunch of spreadsheets it was a
super long email now knowing him now I
know there's no [ __ ] way he read that
email
who's his assistant back in the days
right now is hustling do his own thing
probably read through the whole email
Nate was the name was the admin back
back back then yeah I said him this
really long email with Excel
spreadsheets and the whole thing I made
this comment about do I have to be a
Jets fan I still have in my inbox it's
the corniest thing but I this was 11:30
at night on the west coast 1:30 in the
morning in New York
Gary emails me within 5 minutes and he's
like yep I'm interested let's chat you
know I want you to meet this guy v Kosh
on my team you know talk with him start
with him and so yeah 2:30 yeah yeah yeah
do you think they've got his job do you
think Gabe works here only because of
you yes what happened you saw your
sweater at a hotel is going to get it
okay you sent out some tweet I got 60
emails we've all been on the other side
of that transaction now which is why
it's so funny like onslaught of inbound
that comes in and then it's just trying
to see that they need a lot of the
haystack yeah so maybe so so basically I
hopped on the Skype interview with this
guy V Cox birthing day is not important
I lied I lied to V gosh I told V Kosh I
was gonna be in New York on business why
don't I just stop by the office meet
Gary I do the whole thing so what but
the but my MA I wasn't coming for a job
here so here's the thing I don't thing
you know in the back of my head I
thought well Gary's kind of big in
startups and and reason like maybe I can
read some money from him the slide
saying he just needs to see like what
we've been doing for the last couple
years and how we've been growing the
scaling and it was a whole thing I go
into the office at like it's like at
noon I just gotten into New York the
night before like 1:00 a.m. was on the
red-eye or whatever and I'm completely
bloodshot and I sit down I got this
whole thing in my head that I'm ready to
start talking with him about the first
thing you ask me is a tell me about your
family like time
completely throws me off I had no clue
that was common and and just you talked
to me about the future what vaynermedia
was what you were building what it was
gonna look like in the next three to
four years all these large CMO started
really figuring out what social was and
not just this this game of I think you
know having been here now I know that it
was true but but yeah that was my my
whole thing was I think I can raise
money from Gary and and then he gives me
a job offer on the spot and does ago
[ __ ] on the spot green man and I don't
know what the [ __ ] this companies doing
the way it was better was weird guy gave
oxen his dad's like jazz or something
you told me some story about high school
or college where they were doing
something that felt entrepreneurial I'm
like I like his laugh I'm like [ __ ] it
you want a job yeah
yeah I don't think you need the other
thing yeah now let's go to the part that
I always start to show it will go back
to ladies uh what are you obsessed with
right now and this can be like your
sweater
this show on Netflix the way your wigs
that you wear like what do you like it
doesn't be like World Peace like very
weird and narrow or just or just
actually what are you up you know this
new waffle place this new friend I want
this to be quite broad and interesting
I'm always fascinated by what somebody's
obsessed with right now
what are you obsessed with right now
currently my obsession is YouTube and
vegan lifestyle okay yeah it's so funny
it's like the older I get the more
sensitive my body becomes to like
everything in life so I was a
pescetarian for a while and then all of
a sudden I was a vegetarian and then I
was doing a lot a lot of research on
YouTube about dr. CB and his teachings
and all of that and how more healthy it
is to be alkaline and all that now I was
like you know what let me just change up
my whole eating to another soda like
maybe three weeks ago
good for you three weeks ago so yeah so
like every day I'm researching on
YouTube about vegan lifestyle we got the
right thing you don't know
I mean it's gonna take her at least
another seven weeks to wait that's not
the way I see you executing your content
it's gonna take another seven you
kidding me I gotta like conferences
every day and then I'm like what like I
meet people every day like what do you
do then I call I work in the social
media agency am i cool
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk they're like cool
what do you do that's what you're
obsessed with yes love it yeah on the
macro the vegan lifestyle thing is my
obsession I've been doing it for 11 rich
don't we can talk yeah you'll do that
off Horsley right now like a new pair of
shoes in the micro yeah micro no only in
the micro obsessed with Will Smith on
Instagram yeah incredible yeah he's
doing and it's so he's being authentic
to see a guy like that a less a list not
just dip his toe in the social media but
like completely brother race this is the
game yes great body great my god and
last night on twitch will vlogging and
being on Instagram it's over people
don't get it it went upside down it's
over
amen like it's gonna be interesting to
see who's gonna be next like who's who's
paying attention let me smell let me
save you doing that somebody like the
rock or Kevin Hart or listen that other
people that are a is that getting what
the [ __ ] actually happening but it's
gonna be like here's the words to say
there yeah but I mean what wills doing
is acting more like somebody who's
coming from the bottom correct that's
why you like it wills acting like the
way we all act like starting for the
bottom yeah that's what's interesting
about will like he's authentically juju
Smith like he's doing a lot like when
you feel it coming from the bottom from
when somebody's at the top that's the
the brain twist you get an a-list couple
right now in Hollywood to actually start
vlogging on YouTube the way the family
vlogs do it it will batshit explode the
whole world if you give me any couple
right now that some people magazine or
Us Weekly any of them right yeah [ __ ]
Lake and [ __ ] Gwen Stefani
if they actually started vlogging on
YouTube the way the family vloggers that
are crushing it do it like for real for
real the internet would explode this
boy you did last night when Drake went
[ __ ] into twitch this is what happens
but here's the more interesting part
it's over in my brain and the same way
that I what I told Gabe you know five
and a half years ago it played out in my
brain that's the only thing that exists
for me I'm not even that curious of
who's next for me because it's default
it's going to be everyone because it's
the cost of entry of being relevant in
our society in a decade yeah but not
everyone is gonna be as talented as will
is well that's right in that regard but
there'll be a lot of [ __ ] people that
are talented enough because just
vlogging your life is documented I'm not
creating it yeah so that's the Micra on
the macro I think what's really cool
that's happening right now is seeing
young people socially activated
yesterday was bonkers yeah incredible
what is happening right now these kids
really need raised with these tools who
are putting them into motion in a way
that adults don't understand and
shifting at just culture changing now
these [ __ ] better vote yeah yeah like
to me I'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ] like
marching out of schools [ __ ] fun you
miss school right
being a keyboard warrior on Twitter and
roasting some politician fun you better
get your ass out there you want a really
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up like [ __ ] if
you're turning 18 before November like
[ __ ] go like don't be like like don't
pick [ __ ] twitch over registry like
get your [ __ ] together that's I'm dying
to see what happens 18 to 22 this
November cuz that's how that's the game
mm-hmm this is how I think about social
media like you could be watching my
content or listening to your podcast or
watching Will Smith but if you're not
doing it for yourself you're getting
nothing out of it yeah like you could be
you could be marching and making a sign
and roasting somebody on Twitter but if
you don't [ __ ] boat you [ __ ] suck
kid cool Gabe what are you obsessed with
tracking my biomarkers become a I did my
I did my 23andme last ah and then I
married
my microbiome and and then I use this
company called wellness FX so when are
you dying I'm gonna live forever I feel
like I might - yeah I think it's very
plausible that's why I'm recording
everything I'm gonna be a hologram no
it's quite so I've customized my vitamin
and supplement intake based on my blood
draws I mean my energy levels are super
high what about your scratching ability
cuz you got exposed in your stretching
yeah you set me up by the way it's going
okay the right side I want all of your I
would haunt your entire community know
that you set me up let's talk about this
games like hey we should workout
together cuz he's a beast like yeah he's
strong and everything like if you've
looked at his [ __ ] legs like it's
there right now you've got that ass
workout more time to go so just work out
at my gym oh yeah let's throw some Willy
they think they're tough yeah I knew was
gonna be a stretch day Tyler you were a
disaster description guys for everybody
looking at home if I think somebody can
rival who couldn't do more Tyler I think
is insane real must be but Gabe I knew
could lift more and do more yeah so my
plan always is let's stretch this is
where he beat me by one but did you beat
me by one thank God thank you yes it's
true like two January's ago and then she
beat me by one but now I'll destroy you
um I've progressed but stretching is how
I kill everyone Gabe came in and like
the first part is all do it and I know
where I was two years ago which was
nowhere so you know you see somebody
stretching I'm doing spider-man's and
he's coming and he's looking like yeah
okay whatever right people murdered yeah
Jordan Jordan yeah Jordan had me in all
kinds of positions that I just was not
ready for I should I got my spandex on
I'm I'm like ready to go I've got my my
weightlifting shoes on I'm ready to put
up some real [ __ ] let's talk about your
brand what's been happening I think you
know for me I think the podcast platform
really took you to the next level you
along with Lewis house and I'm Pat Flynn
and jld there was a group of people that
I think about that weren't me in Tim
that weren't me in tony robbins that
were like the next here below this was
your
and grab when did you start your podcast
start the podcast in the in late 2012
perfect exactly yeah point to like penis
picture of what it was like back man I
mean it was still it wasn't cool to have
a podcast exactly right super wonky you
still did download them from your
desktop and bump him to your mp3 player
and you know it wasn't like I was an
early adopter it had been around since
like 2006 or so oh I remember the first
wave but you were part of the earlier
yeah next way you could you could you
could like do a land grab at that point
that's exactly right established sure so
ended apples top 100 chart come out was
it there already when you start is there
it was there already and then and how
were you able to hit it or now oh yeah
right away like right wouldn't when I
look at the number of downloads I was
getting then versus now it's insane what
was the Delta tell him I mean let's be
honest first first couple weeks like mm
maybe and now now 150 to 250 and but
just by having two thousand where would
you rank in the top 100 in in the top
like like in the eighties or not as been
always like Oh business over over oh man
like top three and health which is right
so you're in a top 100 it overall with
2000 or so an episode yeah how often did
you do it once a week
got it we're we uh now set eighty
thousand an episode how many a month
five million yes sir good yeah what
changes up to this to now like once in a
while I'll pop into the top 100 but it's
so much harder and and you know when I
look at the downloads like it's much
more competitive and it's cool to have a
podcast everyone's doing it had I
started now you just you know it
wouldn't it wouldn't have happened do
you believe that you're a know obviously
wrote a book and other stuff but you
know even the podcast was the
quintessential moment that kind of
changed your elevation of your brand yes
but not and I mean it took time I guess
so but is that that's everything slow
the tip of the spear for everything that
I do yeah and so listen the reason I
asked that and why I made a point yeah I
always talk about underpriced attention
in 2012 the podcast was underpriced
attention he went land grabs to his
point it didn't take a whole lot for him
to be the leader there and this is why I
care about an Alexis skill for so many
of you listening right like like
I've got rich actually if you're in town
you should come to voice con we're doing
a really interesting conference on May
22nd in New York I don't know if you're
around but for a bit listening you need
to come to this cuz this is what I if
you asked me hey Gary I'm like the three
of us right personality want to build
stuff like what can I do
everyone's like how do I speed it up how
do I take a shortcut there is no
shortcut even you said right away hey
before before anything else it took a
long time but the only prayer to have a
shortcut by human standards is to win on
the newest platform that's about to
become the platform and you're Alexis
skill every morning around meditation
health vegan like vegan tip if there was
a rich if there was a role tip of the
day that was the dominant alexis skill
three years from now when she was three
weeks in you would have already been
known you know and so so that's the
little thing for that that's why passion
about that so that was it for you how
about for you what was the question
again what was the plot was Instagram
the platform you popped on I mean I said
there are you know are you strong in any
platform besides Instagram and snapchat
is popping how many views are getting on
snapchat
roughly over 6,000 good for you yeah and
so you're at what couple to three
hundred thousand on Instagram I'm at a
little over three hundred and thirty
something something like how many
comments are you getting proposed
roughly mmm comments so probably in the
hood know you sent a thousands on some
of them and are you jumping in there
replying to a bunch yes that's that's
vital
you know it's funny I don't know why but
you know a lot of people that are really
popular and social media I understand if
you're like in the millions you can't
get to everybody but so for some reason
I have found out through conversing with
other people that are popular social
media they don't like to talk back to
their followers and I'm like you're
crazy like I agree it my followers
that's that's what makes a great orange
book right there yes my second book
after me establishing what it all is
yeah is still the reason I think I'm at
like I'm so I mean I'm running on eight
hundred percent two hundred million
dollar company like I'm as busy up
there's nobody I mean I feel real good
where I sit in the um busy category I'm
programmed from 6:00 a.m. to 11:00 p.m.
gaming watch this games running probably
the division I'm most excited about in
the whole company Gabe how many minutes
have we spent together in the last six
months yeah very what do you think less
than two hours
I mean like what the [ __ ] like your
whole life is being an influencer and
you don't have time to [ __ ] answer
comments I do like [ __ ] you yeah no I
actually feel slightly insulted if I
actually slide in somebody's dam that's
lower than mine it's like on some
business stuff or and they don't reply
to me I'm like I have like I'm not like
in the millions but you know it's open
you matter time and we're doing it yeah
like and I was like that's what he said
something to me a can I was a can the
advertising festival last year chatter
John steinberg's got a business kind of
CNBC of the future show and I went to do
like 15 minutes with him it's hard to
get around can you gotta walk traffic
it's just whatever I get there right on
time and he goes and he just looks at me
goes [ __ ] can I go what because you know
we've program like 15 people today and
he goes the three biggest people are you
Mark Cuban and Martin Sorrell who owns
WPP the biggest advertising agency in
the world and he goes you three evolve
in on time he goes the other 12 [ __ ]
are like the VP of Google ads or like
the you know the VP of like future
Twitter activities that he's like and
these [ __ ] are 30 minutes late and
think there's somebody and it really
struck with me like it really struck
with me
it's interesting that's where you're
going with that and like it's how I
sniff out winners and losers real fast
yeah real fast the number one tell for
me of a loser is the second I meet you
in the first hour if I ever have like
when I say a loser I mean somebody
that's actually winning but deep down I
know they have no shot long term is if I
break bread like this or we have dinner
when I met rich I remember this very
vividly if you come clean in the first
hour I meet you you're finished yeah I
think a planing is the TEL and if you
ask me right now what's going on with my
content there's a really interesting
vibe going on because it must be the
cadence of our content I'm getting so
much content from people that are happy
out of depression right now and I cannot
tell you how many of them are completely
predicated on the fact that they don't
make excuses anymore
and they've taken 100% accountability I
genuinely think it's the unlock of
happiness when you think it's all your
fault what you realize is that nobody's
in control and all of a sudden you get
happy mm-hmm it's super interesting
mm-hmm anyway Gabe what's going on with
you know we live public lives you don't
yep front where are you right now with
social media what's your favorite
platform are you using anything what is
your relationship what do you what's
what's in you know these magazines the
end the out the hobby cold what's the
hot what's the cold who's in the last
six months grown with your time and
attention and usage and what have you
fallen off on or gay personally yeah for
me personally I probably straddle
between snapchat and Instagram those are
your two spots as my two spots I spin on
what's the third if at all
medium medium yeah read I read okay I'm
an aggressive reader where is Twitter
hardly at all how often will you open
your Twitter app once every once every
couple weeks Wow toxic Twitter's gotten
real talk how are you - how can you open
YouTube to consume so I've got a smart
TV at home I actually jump on YouTube
that way the new way the Ottawa heights
so like TV where unplugged we don't have
cable anymore Chris Cape yeah yeah
because we do everything through YouTube
[ __ ] okay yeah or so our Smart TV all of
our subscription ah okay so it's instant
snap incidence now I'm hardly ever
checking on Facebook anymore and what's
happening what snap for you on one on
one
yeah I like it's shown yeah Jenny or
York or people that you talk with I've
probably got 12 people who are pretty
consistent are you going to discover and
looking at any of that content hardly
ever got it so today are you are you
consuming people stories I am yes yeah
insta insta is
I just enjoyed I think well I think a
lot of my Facebook friends why don't
check out Facebook anymore but a lot of
my Facebook friends are there so I can
just catch up on outside your friends
what do you follow and then stuff so I'm
like doing gymnastic strength training
these days so I follow a lot of the
older gymnast and what about MBA or CNN
or anything no I mean like what about me
do you follow me of course
yeah wants to show everyday what about
you with social media you're coming from
a different perspective yeah how much
actually let's start with this the
breakdown between a business perspective
and it's just really rich have you never
had this life and the old lawyer rich
what's your breakdown on percentages of
the public versus you actually using it
as a private vehicle in any shape or
form what's the breakdown yeah well I'm
sharing on on most of them except for
snapchat now I'm still romantic about
total real quick real quick out of a
hundred points when you use all these
platforms is it 100% the professional
version of yourself do you have any
actual human interaction like your
normal self like I don't so I do not use
any social media like a normal person I
started it as business it I never grew
up with it as social like my texts met
my texting is my only human place I
don't hit up my friends on social I
don't follow them on social I don't have
a real life with social media it's
always been business it's always been
garyvee that's always been the way it
was so I don't even know the alternative
do you have a normal life on Facebook or
on Twitter or on snap like Gabe does
yeah absolutely and for me as well it's
just normal versus well versus business
it's difficult for me to differentiate
between the two because my personal life
is so blended with my professional life
mine is well ish but you know what I
mean right I know what you mean no you
means you have an interaction with
somebody that is not for public domain
gripes like hey I'll pick up the kids at
4:30 or do you see the game tonight
cuz the only place I'll do that is text
I'll do that no normal I'll do that I'll
do that on Twitter on Twitter and I'll
do that on Instagram with just daily
life stories and then I'll communicate
with friends on DM yeah so on Instagram
and Twitter and so what's emerging for
you what's declining well instead
Instagram is right
very hot that's where I get them what
highest in cold is Twitter although it's
still my favorite because I'm romantic
it's still what I go to first even
though I get the least amount of
engagement there and I love it and you
know I followed news and stuff like that
there as well well what was the question
again so jump into the conversations I'm
like okay what hold high is for hottest
for me is definitely instagrammed second
hottest would be snapchat coldest is
probably YouTube you're just not paying
attention
no no I'm when you when you say hi as
I'm on YouTube as in looking I'm on it
everyday but as far as uploading content
that's what I'm not doing
understood yes Gabe who's the most
interesting person out there to you
right now macro macro conversation
accurate like who's the most interesting
person right now it could be one of
these gymnasts if you who's super like
who are you like really like oh [ __ ] I
just discovered this person I like what
they're doing or I'm learning from them
or I like the way they're doing it you
just probably could be will again which
yeah I mean I really like Aubrey Marcus
right now CEO of on it I think he's he's
got he's got his new book coming out you
know you know that we have a real real
real really is that how you first
discovered him where you knew me I knew
him from the on today's the Joe Rogan
podcast and you know back in those days
five six years ago your about him yeah I
mean well like I like I'm in that yep
I'm in that demo I told I said yeah rich
besides will anybody else or is it will
I mean wills probably at the top right
now front of mine but you know I follow
all different kinds of accounts I like
street art globe I think you know I'm
into art and I think what's going on
without account is super creative yeah
mind car Bella honestly I look at your
stuff a lot when did you first discover
my stuff like two years ago oh really
it's funny how I'm all big about you
know the universe one yes so to meet
this guy I
yeah I had that in my mind like it
doesn't take a lot to manifest I'm
really big on once I want something it's
going to happen it's only a matter of
time what do you want to happen you want
to be the biggest actress or I will be
the biggest one of the biggest actresses
and how do you define that do you find
that as getting paid thirty million
dollars to do no it's like you put the
money but no no forget about that yeah
do you mean that by being the number one
leading lady yeah I just fill me in yes
yeah
me in a lot of people say that but when
it comes like you talk about doing the
work all the time they don't want to do
the work think you can do that in New
York do you feel you have to eventually
move to LA I don't know because I feel
like when the time is right la will come
calling for me do you think you'll get
there before the OTT environment the way
the internet do let me ask you a
question let's ask the roundabout
question everybody answer this do you
believe the biggest film in America 15
years from today which is quite a while
but not really especially for the kids
at home it goes fast right rich
absolutely fifteen years from now do you
believe the biggest film like the Black
Panther of 15 years from today do you
think that is being executed in movie
theaters the way they are now and maybe
the movie theaters have a little bit of
a better setup and maybe the food's
better or maybe it's a little but like
if we all go to a physical place that
kind of basically looks like the theater
Gabe you go first 15 years way VR I mean
like 15 years all the time yeah that
that basically puts us in the 2030s I
mean yeah there's no way we're gonna be
so different there's no richa I think
we'll still be in transition
I think they'll still be theatres there
but as the model number one film the
number one film I think we'll still be
in a theater but but that's it's waning
days you know as a father but a hold on
your old thing it's gonna hold on yeah
because there's something about
experience I think you still get it well
I believe it's in motion already because
films and just writing it takes
sometimes years I get it so yes you
think the number one film in 2033 mm-hmm
is being distributed on its four point
nine billion dollars in revenue Star
Wars have any [ __ ] three distributed
no there's probably another platform not
even create
it's gonna be distributed on yeah I
think my answer is a little bit closer
to riches I actually I actually think VR
is gonna take some real time though I
think 15 starts becoming the interesting
right around the interesting zone
they'll be really I mean the best part
is we're gonna be able to watch this
this is why I love what my life's about
now man I've been thinking a lot I'm
gonna bounce off for a second boy do I
wish I had the film of you know the
first time I went to Twitter so office
the whole company there's six people in
there there are more people in this room
right now when I then when I visit the
Twitter how many employees that company
had people that blog would be it's cool
more like when I spoke the entire
Facebook company and like like just so
many cool more the film of be passing on
uber twice that'd be cool
we're like when Boyd used to sleep in
the office Mac Miller yeah just like all
those times
Nipsey way back then future future titty
boy boy 2 Chainz now it's just all these
moments or when you came to the office
like right now my content in five years
is gonna be able to have you say that
and they're gonna edit that clip from
dailyvee 1:13 when you walked in read
anyway back to film so be interesting
the reason I'm asking you is I think
you'll have to go to LA unless mm-hmm
what's really interesting is that the
Hollywood of the East is clearly now
Atlanta mm-hmm
do you know what's going on with the
outskirts of Atlanta Georgia I don't
know what's going on Marvel a lot of oh
yeah that they're not filming these
movies now in Atlanta right right these
studios that I don't remember to town
they're about an hour outside of Atlanta
but in Georgia because of the tax
benefits right is stealing and building
I'm right Lana's Tyler Perry built
that's exactly right
yeah Marvel I know that Marvel is doing
about just that I am a hundred percent
sure that vaynermedia will have an
office in Atlanta yes a hundred no yeah
I came from Atlanta that's a hot spot
but I came up here specifically for
training because what a lot of people
don't understand is I was in Atlanta and
that's cool for like little independent
artists not not trying to belittle
anybody
you're like yeah but when it yeah that
people take you more seriously hmm you
getting values of working what do you
mean are you learning
oh yes yes and I'm actually already
meeting actors that are in this area
that find me on social media like these
are real actors right so and they're
looking at real attention yes and that's
the game that's the tria
yeah so basically I came up here to get
that good NYC training so they can say
hey Arabelle Arabella we see your resume
and we see that you're serious so you
have training here here here I have
training in Atlanta have training
Augusta have training from LA but now I
want to come to New York and say hey I
have this on my resume
I'm a very serious actor here's
everything I have and then that's when
they're gonna be like okay we know you
wear lead role because you trained for
it lead your Instagram account yes what
was the first popping moment well
content will collab what happened so
you're doing your thing - yeah honestly
I did not start taking Instagram
seriously until about a year and a half
ago what happened if I went viral about
three times worldstar
shout out the worldstar worldstar put me
on the map I'm not gonna lie I was
shocked um I was actually filming two
films two years ago at the same time and
then after I was done there was nothing
else lined up so I had hit up one of
these comedians on Instagram when I was
like hey I like your work on vine no no
no Instagram this guy was like I like
your work or whatever and I was like
nobody knows that I'm funny I think I'm
funny and I was like I like your stuff
so let's just meet up and just make some
skits and he was like okay cool
so we met up you have any followers at
that point I had a little bit I had like
maybe like 17,000 okay
so I made out with him and then I was
like okay so we Machado yeah yeah um do
you remember yeah I remember I don't
work with him for a while I don't mr.
freeze okay mr. freeze
yes mr. freeze we work together and the
first video was called I want some dick
cuz it one baby wants to change yeah and
basically we just put it out there
no you said you said harmony is still on
there but when when we put it out there
I had no idea that it was gonna go viral
like it didn't even go viral it went
like mega viral cuz like it went it went
really popular my page and his pace and
then once worldstar I got it was like
him what everyone yeah and it was crazy
and after that like you're next yeah
yeah yeah then I was like hmm and then
the next to viral of the videos went
viral again yeah and it was like every
time I made something went viral I guess
cuz I'm extra but I'm just a good
actress like but it was just comedy so I
didn't really take it that seriously but
once I started getting so many views and
then people started paying attention
people start asking questions yeah and I
already had I already have an
entrepreneur side that is very strong I
was like hmm let me let me start doing
it so what about the wigs I know when I
looked at your account like back when I
first ever hit like I'm like like is
that like what's that about is that like
real life is that like wait I just love
looking different yeah all the time
because you know I'm naturally like
Spacey and artsy and out there that's -
yeah so like anytime I see like
something that's like oh that's so
unicorn like because everybody knows me
as the original unicorn cuz that's what
I am and if I see it and I'm like that's
unicorn like I have to get it you feel
like you're the original unicorn that
felt like Paris Hilton saying that she
invented the selfie and then the
internet beat her up like I never heard
when I say that I have confidence in
myself as you know a woman beings just
mystical and like something that you've
never seen a woman before you know of
course there was did you bring any wigs
with you huh did you bring any wigs
anyway oh no no I did it no I want to
come natural as possible rich what's
going on - man what do you wanna what do
you want to ask us what do you want to
ask the audience what are you up to what
are you thinking about what's your next
move how are you thinking about things I
got a couple books coming up that are
being released I rewrote finding ultra
and that's coming out this week which is
what brought me to New York
and honestly Gary you know I I'm just
working on
being better and better every day like
unlike you like I've never had a viral
moment yeah it's just been progressive
slowly growth I really haven't had a
viral moment either believe this or not
I've had a lot of things do extremely
but I don't have any video on YouTube
with over 10 million views like you
breathing me Bevin right I've never had
like rich it's really funny like I don't
think I've had a viral moment I've had a
lot of good things going and if it's
about a woman like world star like that
I've had some stuff but like I haven't
had anything good Andy I want to hear
Andy's perspective on this
what a morning ya know I've have some
videos that really and he's gonna be
like Andy have I forgotten viral yes
like what do you consider viral like
what you mean the big like the four
trillion to one in the Monday morning
like we consider those viral like what's
the most viral thing that I that happen
that 130 million that's pretty far away
I want to say get do you Gary you're 42
42 all right
I'm 51 yeah I'm on the Eldar statement
station here here but here's the thing
I didn't even you I liked when you went
back yeah like you were like completely
like clean shape and complete clean ball
when you brought back hair I thought
that was a good move
really yeah shaped I'm not totally sure
I could ever let it no heat what it is
60 of them's clean yeah yeah but here's
my point
I didn't even start really this journey
that I'm on right now until I was older
than you yeah no I get it
and and so for anybody who's listening
or watching television feel like it's
too late like I'm watching bullsh oh
yeah I had a whole past life that led me
to a point that created a health crisis
and an existential crisis about what I
was doing and some confusing years about
trying to figure out like how I wanted
to move forward in the world
as I said in crushing it like your work
has been influential in not just
motivating me but providing me with
tools to really assess that for myself
rich on that no but I'm sorry please
yeah let me just finish this thought
which is you know it's been you know my
life is an embarrassment of riches right
now but it's really a function of hard
work and patience and diligence and and
being really dedicated to the process
and being detached from the results
which is somebody somebody that's at
yeah and couldn't say better way dude
it's the [ __ ] process like you will
look back when you become the biggest
when you put that [ __ ] star in
Hollywood I promise you when you're
sitting with you know the grandchildren
or people that look up to you
you're gonna romance about this time way
more than the [ __ ] hits yeah process
yeah what do you what do you think back
on you know like I've done these crazy
all transgresses yeah but I don't think
about crossing the finish line I think
about that day I didn't want to get out
of bed like that's what gives it meaning
for me yeah and in terms of your
question of like you know what is the
question I want to ask the audience
everything that I've been able to
accomplish is a function a direct result
of investing in trying to more deeply
connect with myself so my question the
audience really is like who are you you
know who the [ __ ] are you and if you
can't answer that question honestly for
yourself you can pick a goal and you can
be motivated by Gary and take advantage
of the tools that he puts out in the
world but you might be climbing a ladder
that's leaning up against the wrong wall
so you really need to take the time to
step back and and really get to know who
you are like what is your design and
what is it that gets you out of bed and
excited and if you can be super honest
about that and like crack the you know
veneer of denial and all these things
that hold you back that is the path
forward but if you want to just leapfrog
over that because you think that's an
inconvenience if then you can go yeah
you can chase stuff your whole life but
you're never gonna be a fully integrated
authentic person and you're never going
to achieve you're never gonna be able to
share what it is that is most valuable
not just to yourself but but to whoever
happens to be paying attention to
whatever they're doing okay what's going
on with beta like I feel like well like
you we feel like I feel if you feel like
we finally got a grass
it's like like this was a company that
was incapable vaynermedia was incapable
of taking the three hundred thousand
dollars a year that tens of thousands of
people want to give vaynermedia because
of me because we were built for the
Budweiser's and the chases and the
biggest companies in the world Gabe was
a unique individual in the organization
it was always entrepreneurial we did
publishing things together I felt that
you were a man for the task I would
argue the first year we were still
trying to like figure it out much the
machine it wasn't you and I feel like
what has happened this is almost like
weirdly me having my own meeting like
what is that what happened like do you
think six months ago or nine months ago
what would like and what have you
learned from the smbs and the mid-market
companies like what's what's happening
like what's it like what's the what's
the nut that you've been able to crack
as a leader of that department
I think wine I actually think it's a
very big there's a I would say argue
that 35 percent of people that are
listening this podcast right now
actually want to do what you're doing
yeah which is they want to be a service
provider or an influencer for small and
medium-sized businesses and and build
their business so it's really
interesting where as you were really
like oh she keeps funny and laughs loud
let me put him in the seat right now
what rich just did was brought a ton of
value reinforcing something I think that
is our joint religion I literally
thought I was just talking what's
interesting is I think you might be able
to give an insight right now that could
change somebody's life because a ton of
these kids are building their own
agencies or services or things of that
nature what was that that you correct
well I think one is I really give a [ __ ]
about these guys and girls are out there
building companies I've walked in their
shoes and you do as well and you give me
lot of leeway to try to figure it out
and taste and try things and experiment
and be able to experiment without you
know being in fear of like well what's
the P&L or making money like what's
what's happening but really trying to
figure out what are these businesses
need I've been in their shoes before you
know how do we add a lot of value I mean
I spend a lot of time with our team I
don't give a [ __ ] what our s.a.w says
deliver value above and beyond work yeah
the statement they ask of a work deliver
value above and beyond what we're
competent right because you're always
giving hours of a creative yes and they
need a picture of video that's gonna pop
and we're at 19 hours the answer is yes
yes do it do it just deliver value the
only
thing that matters is what the I mean
these these people jobs are at stake
people's livelihoods are at stake
like you've got to treat it seriously so
we just try to deliver a [ __ ] ton of
those two meetings by the way for your
team today mm-hmm good yeah
done it's fun when I break them yeah
hundred percent man
it's my finger of oldies big company
this process yes [ __ ]
I hate process yeah and so like
sometimes when you get [ __ ] done they're
just like coming in and throwing out the
process we've just so we were trying to
fit everybody into the traditional
agency model and we figured out that's
not gonna work
and so we started figuring out what we
went to the back to the drawing board
and said what's the 80/20 what what are
we always doing what do clients always
need we had a lot of great clients in
the very beginning that just we're like
hey I I know my business but no
marketing let's help people yeah things
like we delivered we were able to
prioritize the new web builds especially
for e-commerce companies we're able to
build marketing automation product flows
so that they can connect their
first-party CRM data with their POS data
with their Facebook or Instagram data
and make sure that all those pipes are
connected and talking to one another and
just put automated user flows we haven't
figured out a brand name creative launch
product yet right so we do we do we have
a particle accelerator I've been
thinking yeah we about we have a product
called the excitement it's still
expensive though it's how much as it's a
six-week project
it comes with video production and all
the cut downs that you need for your
media plan a six week flight and then
the post mortem and executing the media
plan the creative is gonna cost about a
hundred 125k expensive we were gonna
cost 50 K and then the media is gonna be
like another 75 to 100 K so it's still
it's it's a six-figure product still got
it but oh yeah yeah son butter
originally shot son butters and Justin
those guys Barney Anna shout outs of
Barney Anna and Nick and that team let's
go back to the point here if somebody's
listening right now they're starting
their own agency
it's them by themselves they're trying
to get over that first hump if they can
make $25,000 someway somehow they can
take that money like that's their thing
and they're all kids and
they wanna be do social media for the
neighborhood restaurant yeah from what
you've seen cuz you're much closer to
that and a lot of them are playing in
that $500 a month $1,000 one-off but
like if your one recommendation for the
husks are out there Karen you know and
and Yanni Magoo
I'm telling what's the right thing that
they should try to get 5000 bucks for or
1500 and now understand how paid media
works and be able to look at the
analytics and help businesses scale
their customers that's it's it's Matt
it's the math with the creative together
like you've just got to learn how those
worlds work together and if you can
figure that part out and actually be
able to look at the data and make
informed decisions and grow customers as
a result a lot of our clients they know
their business but that part it starts
getting wonky it's weird they're not
super comfortable with it it just can
deliver so much value we're gonna end
with the speed round favorite color blue
orange green favorite number seven four
eight it's for you real number favorite
number like flat out yeah cool just mine
you should start doing the four favorite
TV show you're watching now hey mates to
homeland the dailyvee I'm the big TV guy
I'm on YouTube and yeah I'm watching
podcasts on YouTube favorite athlete of
all time uh Kobe Bryant Eric Hyden
there's a curve ball very good you know
what I'm talking to to be real not even
in sports like I'm not a buret Disney
character and or cartoon character I'll
favorite cartoon carrier the oh my gosh
talk it out it is right there I can't
even think
terney Lola the one on the one who has
the red hair and she'll or me no no no
no no oh [ __ ] yes from Roger Rabbit oh
just a rabbit yes yes we all remember
her
I don't even know I can't even speak of
her we're does have a rich Popeye oh
yeah sailor man is yes yes the spinach
yeah yeah come on brother
you said Disney rooms in Miami it went
immediately to Aladdin Aladdin yeah I
love it
guys I really appreciate you guys being
on the show podcast listeners I hope you
enjoyed it
voice con I'm serious I'm throwing a
right hook at the end I can just feel it
in my bones that I'm about to embark
into the next frontier of my career it's
around voice it's podcast it's Alexis
skills it's all that whether you come to
the conference or not just dig in dig in
it's the opportunity its emerging its
realest [ __ ] all of you are gonna be
using voice over texting for a ton of
things that you can't be thinking about
right now so I'm just excited about it's
that next weird having rich here I think
is inspired me 2012 podcast three
[ __ ] weeks and top 100 virality
people are watching it matters this
could be your moment a lot of fun things
covered in the show hope you enjoyed it
Seth good job we'll see you next time on
pod sessions
you